We're on problem 60.
Given the equation y is equal
to x to the n where x is
greater than 0 and n is
less than 0, which
statement is valid?
So let's see, x is greater than
0 and n is less than 0.
So the exponent is negative,
but the base is positive.
So I'll just tell
you right now.
Your gut reaction might be to
say, oh, if I have a negative
exponent, maybe I somehow
end up with a
negative number somehow.
But you have to remember, a
negative exponent, it just
tells you that it's really
just the inverse of the
positive exponent.
So this is equal to 1 over
x to the minus n.
And if n is less than
0, then minus n is
greater than 0, right?
So you could say this is the
same thing as 1 over x to some
other letter m, where m is minus
m, but then m would be
greater than 0, right?
So no matter how negative this
exponent is, especially if
this base is positive, you're
going to end up with a
positive number.
You're going to end up with very
small fractions if this
gets large enough.
It could be 1 over x to the
hundredth power or something.
So it could be a very
small number.
It can approach zero.
But it will always be
a positive number.
So y is always going to
be greater than 0.
Choice A.
Problem 61.
If x is a real number, which
best describes the value of x
for which the inequality
the square root of x
greater than 0 is true?
So I'm assuming we're dealing
with the real numbers, and if
I get an imaginary number here,
it's actually just even
hard to compare it in terms
of magnitude to 0.
So they're actually just asking
us what the domain is.
What x's can we put in here and
get an answer where we can
make some type of sense
out of the statement?
So obviously, I could put
a positive x here.
x could be greater than 0.
Any x greater than 0 will
have a square root.
And all of their square roots
will be greater than 0.
I mean, you could square both
sides of that equation and you
get x is greater than 0.
You could put x is equal to 0
there, but then the inequality
wouldn't be true, right?
Because the square root
of 0 is equal to 0.
So if you put x is equal to 0
there, that would work, you
can take the square root of 0,
but it just won't make the
inequality true.
So x can't be equal to 0.
So x can be greater than 0.
It can't be greater than
or equal to 0.
Not all values of x work.
I can't put a negative
number in there.
I mean, they say
no values of x.
No, sure.
We can put any positive number
there that works.
So the answer is A.
Next problem.
Let me turn the page.
Let me copy and paste.
Which of the following
conclusions is true about the
statement below: x squared is
equal to the square root of x.
All right, so once again,
let's think
about it a little bit.
x squared is equal to the
square root of x.
I mean, it definitely works for
the number 1 and it works
for the number 0.
If you square both sides of that
equation, you get x to
the fourth is equal to x.
x could be equal to 0, but if
you assume that x does not
equal 0, you could divide both
sides of this equation by x
and you get x to the third
is equal to 1.
And the only number that
I know works for that
is the number 1.
But anyway, the statement
is always true.
No, it's not always true.
I put a 2 there.
Is 2 squared equal to the
square root of 2?
No, 4 does not equal the
square root of 2.
So the statement is
not always true.
The statement is true
when x is negative.
No, x can't even be negative.
You can't take the square root
of a negative number.
You'd end up with imaginary
numbers and it
just gets very strange.
The statement is true when
x is equal to 0.
Sure.
It could be 0.
The statement is never true.
No.
Clearly, it's true when x is
equal to 0 or x is equal to 1.
So the answer is C.
I didn't even have to do this
stuff on the side right here.
But, hopefully, it
was instructive.
Next problem.
I copied it now I
have pasted it.
All right.
Let me try with the
larger pen.
Abelardo wants to create several
different 7-character
screen names.
He wants to use arrangements of
the first three letters of
his first name, ABE-- that's
why they made his name
Abelardo-- followed by
arrangements of the 4 digits
in 1984, the year
of his birth.
How many different screen
names can he
create in this way?
All right, so he's got 7.
So think about it.
Let's just think about
each slot.
So slot number 1-- that
pen's too fat.
Slot number 1, slot number 1,
spot number 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So slot number 1, how many
different choices
can he put in there?
He can put in an A,
a B or an E there.
So he has three different
choices for slot number 1 I'll
do that in a different color.
He has three different choices
for slot number 1.
Once he picks slot number 1, how
many choices does he have
left for slot number 2?
Well, he has two letters left
out of the A, B and E, right?
So he has only two
options left.
And once he gets to slot number
3, he has to just pick
whatever leftover letter
is there in A, B and E.
So he only has one option.
But then when he gets to fourth
digit, now he's trying
to pick from 1984.
For the fourth digit, once he
has four options, he can pick
the 1, the 9, the 8 or the 4.
He has four options.
Then on the fifth digit, he
would have picked one of the
four, so he has three
of them left.
By the sixth digit, he only
has two of them left.
By the seventh digit, he's
forced to pick whatever's
leftover, what he hasn't
picked yet.
He has one digit left.
So the combinations, you just
multiply all of them.
3 times 2 is 6 times 1 is 6.
6 times 4 is 24.
24 times 3 is 72.
72 times 2 is 144
times 1 is 144.
So there's 144 different
screen names he can
create in this way.
Next problem.
64.
I've copied it.
And now I'm pasting it.
A train is made up of a
locomotive, seven different
cars and a caboose.
If the locomotive must be first
and the caboose must be
last, how many different ways
can the train be ordered?
So we don't even have
to worry about the
locomotive and the caboose.
They're always going to be
in the same position.
The locomotive's first, caboose
is last. So we just
have to worry about the seven
different cars, the order that
they're in.
It's really the same problem
as the last one.
In some ways, it's a
little bit easier.
So let's just say that's
the position.
Position 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
And let's say we just have to
decide which car we put in
each position, or how many
different options do we have.
So let's say we are filling
the slots starting with
position 1.
Well, we have seven cars
to choose from.
The seven is different
from them.
That's not including the
locomotive and the caboose, so
we have seven cars
to pick from.
We've picked one of them.
Then in slot 2, we have
six cars to pick from.
Slot 3, we have five cars to
pick from because we've
already picked two.
And in slot 4, four
cars to pick from,
three cars, two cars.
And then in slot 7, we've
already picked six of the
cars, so whatever's leftover,
we have to pick.
So let's see what
this number is.
1 times 2 is 2.
2 times 3 is 6.
6 times 4 is 24.
24 times 5 is 120.
120 times 6 is 720.
720 times 7-- I'm just going
to have to do a little bit
multiplication here on the
side-- 720 times 7.
7 times 0 is 0.
7 times 2 is 14.
7 times 7 is 49 plus 1 is 50.
5,040.
So there's 5,040 different
ways that the
train can be ordered.
Let's see.
Next problem.
Maybe I'll just clear
all of this.
All right.
Let me copy the-- all right.
Teresa and Julia are among 10
students who have applied for
a trip to Washington, D.C.
Two students from the group
will be selected at
random for the trip.
What is the probability that
Teresa and Julia will be the
two students selected?
So let's think about this.
There are 10 students who have
applied for the trip.
Two students from the group
will be selected at
random for the trip.
What is the probability Teresa
and Julia will be the two
students selected?
All right, so let's think about
student 1 selected and
student 2 selected.
What's the probability that
Teresa is the first student?
So what's the probably that we
get Teresa and then we get
Julia, that Teresa is the first
student selected and
that Julia is the second
student selected?
Well, the probability that
Teresa is the first-- well,
let me take a step back.
There's two ways that what
they want to happen could
happen, that Teresa and
Julia will be the
two students selected.
Either Teresa is the first
student selected and then
Julia is the second; or Julia is
the first student selected
and Teresa is the second.
So if we figure out the
probability of this happening
and the probability of this
happening, then we can just
add those probabilities together
and then we have the
probability of either
of those happening.
All right, so let's do that.
The probability of Teresa
happening is-- let me do this
in a different color.
There's 10 students, so there's
a probability that we
pick Teresa first. And then
once we've picked Teresa
first, the probability that we
pick Julia next, well, now
there's 9 students
left, right?
Because you've already picked
Teresa, so there's a 1 in 9
chance you pick Julia.
So that is equal to 1 in 90.
So there's a 1 in 90 chance
of this happening.
There's a 1 in 90 chance
of that happening.
And then what's the chance
of this happening?
What's the chance of
that happening?
Well, it's the same thing.
This is 1 in 10 and this
is 1 in 90, right?
And so you have a 1 in 90
chance of it happening.
And so, what is the probability
of either of these
things happening?
Of this combination or
this combination?
Well, you just add them
together, and you get 2 out of
90, which is equal to 1 out
of 45, which is choice A.
And I'm out of time.
See you in the next video.